temps nous sommes avec ryad au bep j
président du conseil de la banque privée
des mots bonjour à vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation d'abord cette
question avant d'évoquer la situation
économique du liban
est ce que la classe dirigeante
libanaise et corrompu comme le dénonce
les manifestants qui descendent dans la
rue
c'est difficile de savoir qui est
corrompu qui n'est pas corrompue pour
moi on ne peut pas danser des
accusations sans qu'il y ait des profs
alors il n'y a pas il n'y a pas eu de
jugement pour l'instant ce sont des on
dit alors moi je ne suis pas capable de
jeter la pierre à quelqu'un ce pas
simplement de rondi tout cas ce que
dénonce les manifestants c'est une
classe dirigeante qui monopolise une
grande partie des richesses si on veut
résumer ainsi la situation
est-ce que ça correspond à une certaine
réalité
mais c'est la même chose c'est l'offre
on dit que les il ya eu de la collection
pour 300 milliards de dollars
c'est clair que c'est faux parce que
l'économie libanaise se pose pas autant
on ne peut pas avoir volé 300 milliards
quand toute l'économie libanaise parce
que 50 milliards alors est-ce qu'ils ont
monopolisé l'essentiel je ne vois pas ça
mais mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas mon
métier de chef alors justement là on va
parler de la crise économique la
situation du système bancaire libanais
la dette du pays qui atteint plus de
150% du pib on comprend bien que ça
fragilise le tissu économique du pays
selon les médias les banques sont en
faillite au liban c'est vrai c'est faux
vous avez
vous même une filiale là-bas au liban
alors je crois que ce que la la crise a
démontré c'est d'abord de la force de la
l'économie libanaise parce que il ne
faut pas oublier que cette crise n'est
pas arrivé comme ça d'un seul coup à la
suite de quelques manifestations non il
y à il ya eu deux chocs extrêmes qui
sont considérables
il y à il ya une guerre à toutes les
frontières praticable du sud du liban
depuis depuis déjà plus de dix ans il y
à un afflux de réfugiés il n'y a plus
d'un million de réfugiés
il ya eu aussi une certaine angoisse qui
a conduit les libanais à ou sortir de
l'argent du pays ou à garder de l'argent
chez eux ou à ne pas envoyer au liban
pour fin on estime que les montants
soient peuplés 20 ans pour mettre ça en
perspective
imaginez qu'en france il ya eu une
guerre fait simultanément en belgique en
allemagne en italie en espagne
qu'est ce qui se serait passé en france
qu'est ce qui se serait passé si jamais
il y avait eu 20 millions de réfugiés en
france
qu'est ce qui se serait passé si jamais
il y avait lu milliards d'euros qui
étaient sortis du symbole caire alors au
liban le liban a tenu mal mais il a tenu
à mon avis ça démontre la force de
l'économie libanaise
alors est-ce que la situation est bonne
la situation est mauvaise mais je ne
pense pas que la solution ce soit ou de
s'entretuer ou de se jeter la pierre ou
de trouver des boucs émissaires ou des
dont il faut profiter de la force que
nous avons de la force que nous avons
démontré renforcer nos forums essayer
d'améliorer nos faiblesses
la situation des banques au liban vous
vous inquiète-t-elle et inquiétante où
le nom alors
les banques vif sur une économie si
jamais l'économie s'effondre évidemment
que les banques ne peuvent pas se tirer
d'affaires si jamais l'économie se
dirige à faire les banques aussi se dire
on affecte donc c'est celle il n'y a pas
de n'est pas de différence entre vous
êtes inquiet personnellement je ne suis
pas inquiet mais j'suis doc caractère
d'une mathieu optimisme comment le
gouvernement peut rectifier le tir
aujourd'hui le gouvernement d'hassan
diab
pour réponse peut-être mieux aux
revendications des manifestants alors il
ya les revendications des manifestants
il ya aussi la crise économiqu e qui est
pour moi d'abord une crise morale et les
gens paniquent
c'est pour ça qu'ils gardent de l'argent
chez eux ils potentiel de l'agent à
l'extérieur pour vous donner une idée on
estime qu'il ya dans les maisons 4
milliards de dollars 4 milliards de
dollars dont pour faire un une
comparaison avec la france c'est comme
si jamais en france il avait 250
milliards d'euros dans leurs maisons
vous imaginez 250 milliards d'euros dans
leurs maisons si c'est de la folie
les gens sont paniqués il faut des
rassurer mais il faut aussi répondre à
la crise les gens ont raison de se
plaindre qu'on ne s'occupe pas d'eux
qu'on les qu'on néglige les gens qui
sont qui dorment dans la rue parce qu'il
y en a qui dorment dans la rue
s'il ya une crise morale que le
gouvernement doit à des lycées et il ya
aussi à l'assuré à a chassé cette ce
sentiment de panique quand on voit les
images justement lors du vote pour
relancer cette loi concernant le budget
les manifestants qui ont tenté
d'empêcher ce vote
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire et
qu'est ce que cela se démontre
finalement sur la situation aujourd'hui
au liban et sur la crise que votre pays
traverse l'ofs
j'avoue que je ne sais pas très bien qu
est-ce qui a enchaîné pas regarder mais
mais parmi les manifestants il ya de
tout et on ne peut pas conclure fin sur
les désirs du peuple simplement se base
de quelques images qui apparaissent à la
télévision même la vôtre donc je ne peux
pas tirer une conclusion claire et
l'avenir de votre pays comment est ce
que vous le voyez je vous ai dit au tout
début que cette crise démontre que la
force de cette économie là je pense que
si jamais on utilise cette crise comme
une opportunité pour nous améliorer
je pense que le liban à un avenir
brillant
vous êtes optimiste alors moi je suis
dans l'eau merci beaucoup
ryad oblige rappelle que vous êtes le
président du conseil de la banque privée
un bémol merci à vous